[Musik]
corona und die folgen das ganze
ruhrgebiet ist jetzt risikogebiet und
dem berchtesgadener land darf man nur
noch mit triftigen grund raus streit
über corona politik die briten finden
keinen gemeinsamen nenner im kampf gegen
die pandemie und verwurzelt und
entwurzelt über jüdisches leben in
deutschland informiert das
wiedereröffnete jüdische museum in
frankfurt am main
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport an schulen kitas und
restaurants sind zu seit 14 uhr darf
niemand mehr ohne grund sein zuhause
verlassen 2000 touristen müssen abreißen
das berchtesgadener land erlebt gerade
wie schnell es gehen kann von der ferien
idylle zum corona hotspot strikte
maßnahmen wenn auch nicht ganz so streng
wie neben dem landkreis in der
österreichischen gemeinde kochel
sie ist seit vergangener woche komplett
unter quarantäne
im berchtesgadener land zählt man pro
100.000 einwohner jetzt 258
neuinfektionen so viele wie nirgendwo
sonst in deutschland petra neubauer wie
leer gefegt wird die fußgängerzone von
bad reichenhall an diesem nachmittag
seit 14 uhr also gelten strenge ausgangs
beschränkungen im ganzen landkreis wird
in ulrike wallner ist sauer sieht sich
für die unvernunft weniger bestraft
wir haben uns ja alle an den
vorschriften gehalten
die größten teil also die haben sich ja
an allen richtlinien gehalten und wir
müssen schließen schulen und kitas im
landkreis sind bereits zu der
einzelhandel aber das öffnen und tut das
auch nur die kunden bleiben aus
sie sehen wir jetzt selber dass die
stadt leer ist und die leute alle
verunsichert sind das die meinen halt
die geschäfte haben jetzt auch der ort
anger hier soll es große privatpartys
gegeben haben sie allein seien aber
keinesfalls der grund für die enorm
gestiegenen corona zahlen heißt es am
nachmittag flüchtig über den gesamten
landkreis haben wir diffuse lage ohne
dass man das einem herd oder zwei gärten
zu stellen können warum wir heute hier
im berchtesgadener land dort stehen wo
wir stehen und das bedeutet auch dass
nun mehr als 2.000 touristen abreißen
müssen bei den einheimischen stoßen die
neuen maßnahmen nicht nur auf zustimmung
weder todesfälle nur sind unsere
intensivstationen überfüllt
es spricht nichts dafür und deswegen
finde ich einfach dass es zu so zum
start genau so zu sagen wir zu krass im
ausnahmen seien was sein muss muss sein
die selbst zwei wochen lang sollen die
beschränkungen für das berchtesgadener
land nun gelten die hoffnung hier ist
groß dass sie nicht verlängert werden
müssen
im ziemlich ausgestorbenen berchtesgaden
ist für uns patricia schäfer patricia
wie reagieren die menschen auf diese
einschränkungen ja barbara erstaunlich
verständnisvoll denn tatsächlich erleben
hier 80 prozent der geschäftsleute von
touristen und die werden in den nächsten
zwei wochen ausbleiben
und auch die einheimischen werden nicht
so einkaufen gehen wie sonst trotzdem
hören wir ja wir haben verständnis sagen
die leute ja konnte ja so nicht
weitergehen und wir werden nur noch
schlimmer und schlimmer geworden es gibt
auch aber vereinzelt leute die kein
verständnis haben die sich trotzdem dran
halten die aber sagen das sei
übertrieben
das sei panikmache aber man sieht die
zahlen die haben die leute hier auch
schockiert letzte woche hat es noch 50
in den instanzen gegeben sieben tage
incidents und dann am wochenende ist es
auf über 250 gestiegen
da musste etwas passieren das denken die
leute hier die politik hat eingegriffen
und hat diese strengen ausgangs
beschränkungen verhängt ein lockdown das
sagte der landrat heute noch mal sei das
aber nicht ist es auch nicht denn es
kann noch viel strenger gehandhabt
werden und die leute können hier noch
spazieren gehen sie können zur arbeit
gehen sie können den landkreis verlassen
und das ist eben nur eine strenge
ausgangs beschränkung jetzt erstmal für
14 tage im berchtesgadener land
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
berchtesgaden patricia schäfer war das
schauen wir auf die landesweiten corona
zahlen
der aufwärtstrend bei den neuinfektionen
ist ungebrochen 6868 neue fälle meldet
das robert-koch-institut am vergangenen
dienstag lag der wert noch bei 4122 ein
sattes plus also von 7 und 6
sich von dienstag zur dienstag auch der
sieben tagesschnitt geht klar in eine
richtung nach oben
wo sich das virus besonders massiv
ausbreitet zeigt diese deutschlandkarte
immer mehr rot markierte städte und
kreise kämpfen mit sprunghaft
angestiegenen fallzahlen und in berlin
zieht der senat die zügel weiter an in
der hauptstadt gilt jetzt auch eine
erweiterte masken pflicht für belebte
einkaufsstraße ein wichtiges instrument
zur eindämmung des virus ist die kontakt
nachverfolgung zuständig sind die
gesundheitsämter doch die sind immer
häufiger überfordert im hotspot berlin
neukölln etwa kann ein mitarbeiter
höchstens zwei fälle pro tag bearbeiten
denn auf jeden infizierten kommen im
schnitt zwischen 20 und 40 personen die
kontaktiert werden müssen
in anderen regionen sieht es ähnlich aus
auch im ruhrgebiet seit heute komplett
risikogebiet arbeiten die
gesundheitsämter am limit
immerhin bekommen sie jetzt hilfe
angeboten wie geht es ihnen
gesundheitlich von schulnoten 1 bis 6 1
ist sehr gut sehr schlecht obergefreiter
minister fritzenkötter arbeitet seit
knapp einer woche im gesundheitsamt
dortmund zusammen mit 39 anderen
soldatinnen und soldaten unterstützt sie
bei der kontakt verfolgung von coop 19
infizierten
denn die rund 100 mitarbeiterinnen des
amtes kamen irgendwann nicht mehr
hinterher
die eine frau aus allein stehen die
andere frau die hat jetzt fünf kinder zu
hause
innerhalb kürzester zeit hatten sich in
dortmund rund 2000 unbearbeitete corona
kontakte angesammelt deshalb hatte die
stadt bei der bundesregierung antrag auf
amtshilfe gestellt wie viele andere
kommunen auch im grunde genommen haben
wir extra für die amtshilfe ein
kontingent von 15.000 soldatinnen und
soldaten aufgestellt
die nicht besonders spezialisiert sind
wir denn die auch helfende hände
seit heute gilt das ganze ruhrgebiet als
risikogebiet auf der karte des
robert-koch-instituts zieht sich ein
roter streifen von bielefeld bis zur
belgischen grenze bei aachen in dortmund
liegt die sieben tage incidents aktuell
bei rund 70 doch was passiert wenn sie
steigt vermutlich bis eine bis zu einer
existenz von etwa 100 auch in der lage
sein können das geschehen weitgehend zu
beherrschen darüber würde ich dann sagen
ist das eher ausgeschlossen dass man
noch das geschehen beherrscht immerhin
den stau der rund 2.000 unbearbeiteten
corona kontakte konnten die soldatinnen
und soldaten des versorgungsbataillons
mittlerweile abarbeiten
corona in deutschland wie geht's weiter
in der pandemie mit dieser frage
beschäftigt sich ein zdf spezial gleich
nach unserer sendung und in unserer app
haben wir ein interview mit einer
psychologin was corona mit der psyche
macht alarmierend auch die zahlen in
irland dort gilt ab morgen mitternacht
die höchste corona stufe heißt sechs
wochen lang eine treffen mit anderen
haushalten fast alle geschäfte schließen
aktuell meldet ireland gut 1000
neuinfektionen bei nur fünf millionen
einwohnern
beim nachbarn großbritannien haben sich
mehr als 21.000 menschen neu angesteckt
doch dort geht jeder landesteil
unterschiedlich gegen korona vor wales
tut das nun vergleichsweise strikt yasin
herrlein berichtet die walliser machten
schon immer gern alles ein bisschen
anders als ihre nachbarn in england
freitag gibt es hier für zwei wochen
einen kurzen harten locker und alles
bleibt geschlossen außer leben die
lebensnotwendige waren verkaufen
die meinungen darüber gehen auseinander
ich glaube das ist übertrieben zumal
nicht sicher ist ob diese lockt uns auch
nur den geringsten unterschied machen
es muss getan werden ich habe mir die
zahlen angeschaut sie sind sehr schnell
gestiegen großbritanniens corona politik
gleicht einem flickenteppich nicht nur
die einzelnen länder des königreichs
verfolgen ihre eigenen maßnahmen auch
innerhalb england herrscht uneinigkeit
die regierung versucht eine regional
abgestufte strategie stößt aber auf
widerstand
seit zehn tagen betreibt der
bürgermeister von manchester einen
kleinen privatkrieg mit boris johnson
ohne ausreichende finanzielle
unterstützung will er seiner stadt die
aktuell höchste beschränkung stufe nicht
zumuten wie zog bis dann tun das für
euch und wir werden weiter für euch
kämpfen und eure gesundheit an erster
stelle setzen aber gesundheit ist mehr
als nur das virus
johnson hatte bis heute ein ultimatum
gesetzt was er ja zuletzt gerne macht
und will nun strengere maßnahmen ohne
einwilligung von vor ort durchsetzen
doch dies ist riskant hier geht es um
mehr als nur gesundheitspolitik das ist
den menschen in manchester bewusst es
hat in diesem land schon immer ein
nord-süd-gefälle gegeben ich hoffe aber
sie können sich noch einigen über
großbritanniens corona politik hat sich
bisher wenig rühmliches sagen lassen
ohne einigkeit aber droht alles immer
tiefer ins chaos zu stürzen
zur innenpolitik da gab es einiges hin
und her über eine rechtsextremismus
studie bei der polizei jetzt hat sich
die regierung auf einen kompromiss
verständigt und der sieht so aus es wird
eine studie zu rassismus in der
gesellschaft geben und eine weitere über
den polizeialltag in der soll es dann
auch um extremismus gehen aber eben auch
um gewalt und hass gegen beamte
innenminister seehofer betont die
überwältigende mehrheit der polizei
stehe zur verfassung daten sind
bekanntlich ein hohes gut sowohl für
unternehmen wie auch für privatpersonen
ihr schutz sei in der korona krise aber
vernachlässigt worden heißt es im
jahresbericht des bundesamts für
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
die lage hierzulande sei angespannt
cyber kriminelle hätten zuletzt massiven
schaden angerichtet sei es mit angriffen
auf unternehmen kliniken
energieversorger oder banken inzwischen
machen kriminelle mit cybercrime mehr
geld als mit dem verkauf von drogen die
us-regierung gegen google
das justizministerium nimmt den
internet-riesen mit einer
wettbewerbsklage ins visier der vorwurf
google missbrauche seine
marktbeherrschende stellung bei der
suche im internet und damit auch beim
geschäft mit der werbung etwa 90 prozent
der weltweiten suchanfragen laufen über
google
das unternehmen hat sich noch nicht zu
den vorwürfen geäußert wichtige
nachricht für die deutschen
ostseefischer sie müssen weitere
einschnitte hinnehmen die eu hat die
fangquoten für das nächste jahr
festgelegt besonders wichtig für die
fischer der hering und ausgerechnet von
dem dürfen sie künftig nur noch halb so
viel fangen damit die bestände eine
chance haben sich zu erholen
etwas besser die lage bei der sprotte
und scholle um rund fünf prozent hat die
eben die quoten für diese fische erhebt
jetzt so eine region die schon lange von
hunger und elend geprägt ist die sahel
zone auf einer virtuellen geberkonferenz
wurden heute nach ersten schätzungen 1,4
milliarden euro für hilfe gesammelt die
dort dringend gebraucht wird
in der sahel zone im norden afrikas wird
die armut noch verschärft von
naturkatastrophen von gewalt und
islamistischen terror besonders brisant
ist die lage in mali niger und burkina
faso allein dort sind mittlerweile 13
millionen menschen auf hilfe angewiesen
tim krüger berichtet eine karge hütte
ist alles was man nie bei die nie
geblieben ist sein schicksal steht für
das von vielen millionen menschen in der
sache region gewalt vertreibung hunger
unsicherheit nach mehreren überfällen
auf seinen dorf im norden burkina fasos
musste er fliehen
wir sind muslime aber einige unserer
jüngeren brüder sind christen
an einem sonntag bietet es in der kirche
menschen aus dem bus kamen töteten sie
den pastor nur die frauen und kinder
verschont
vor allem hier in burkina faso
verschlechtert sich die lage zunehmend
islamistische terror kriminalität
ethnische konflikte und der klimawandel
setzen den menschen zu wie so oft leiden
die kinder besonders 2002 1300 schulen
sind wegen des konflikts geschlossen
lehrer rennen um ihr leben fast drei
millionen kinder gehen allein in burkina
faso nicht mehr in die schule in buckner
versuche lohn trotz militärischer
interventionen und internationaler hilfe
die krise im saal spitze sich auch wegen
cupid 19 zu so hilfsorganisationen die
menschen vor ort müssten mehr einbezogen
werden sagen traditionelle führer
die kommunen sind die ersten opfer sie
müssen bei der suche nach lösungen mit
in seiner gegend sei es zuletzt immerhin
etwas ruhiger geworden sagt dass mein
lieber die nie angst und unsicherheit
aber bleiben ganz anderes thema jetzt
frankfurt jüdisches museum hat sich
vergrößert und öffnet weder nach fünf
jahren bauzeit
es ist ein haus das geschichte und
gegenwart verbindet nicht nur
architektonisch und es ist ein museum
das geschichte in geschichten erzählt
bis in die heutige zeit peter wagner
hatte sich angeschaut
strahlend hell voller licht außen und
innen das erneuerte und erweiterte
jüdische museum ist auch eine antwort
auf den dunkelsten teil deutscher
geschichte jüdische bürger und familien
prägten jahrhundertelang frankfurt bis
die meisten von ihnen im massenmord der
nazis ihr leben verloren
diese stadt frankfurt ein zentrum
jüdischen lebens in europa und die
bedeutung dessen wie wir denn und juden
in dieser stadt gelebt wie sie diese
stadt geprägt haben wie sie europaweit
gewirkt haben dafür vom frau aufgabe das
zu vermitteln
sichtbar greifbar ergreifend wird es bei
anne frank und ihrem liese stühlchen die
geschichte der familie frank wurzel über
generationen in frankfurt die von anne
endet 1945 im konzentrationslager von
bergen belsen
es ist neues jüdisches leben gewachsen
unter der frankfurter skyline
sportvereine eine literarische gemeinde
streitbare kunst kultur aller sparten
man wird aus diesem museum mit mehr
fragen raus gehen als mit antworten und
genau das wollen wir weil es geht uns
darum zum nachdenken anzuregen bestens
geeignet dazu die skulptur von ariel
schlesinger zwei bäume der eine
entwurzelt der andere fest im boden sehr
schön jetzt sport tennis atp-turnier in
folge in köln wieder mit doppel das
viertelfinale erreicht alexander zverev
uns sein älterer bruder micha ein klarer
zweisatzsieg im spiel gegen den briten
dominik englert und dem pakistani aisam
ul haq qureshi alexander und mischa
zverev zeigen sich deutlich besser
sortiert und schlagt stärker als noch
vor einer woche als sie frühzeitig bei
der ersten ausgabe des turniers in köln
ausschieden gegen das britisch
pakistanische doppel brauchen dies wäre
es nur 38 minuten um den ersten satz mit
6 4 für sich zu entscheiden
starke aufschläge gutes verständnis und
herausragendes spiel am netz sind ein
schlüssel zum erfolg ein weiterer
alexander zverev sieg im einzel
vergangenen sonntag und dementsprechend
mitreißenden selbstbewusstsein mit 6 4
und 6 2 gewinnen ihrer brüder im
viertelfinale könnten sie auf die french
open sieger kevin krawietz und andreas
mies treffen titelverteidiger primoz
watch hat zum auftakt der
spanien-rundfahrt walter die erste
bergetappe gewonnen der slowene setzte
sich auf dem schlussanstieg nach parade
kurz vor dem ziel ab und sprintete
seinen konkurrenten aus der
spitzengruppe davon rät caracas aus
ecuador wurde zweiter der ire daniel
martin dritter champions league der bvb
tritt heute abend mit einer geschwächten
abwehr bei lazio rom an und trifft auf
einen alten schwarz-gelben bekannten
italiens torschützenkönig in dortmund
überzeugte giro immobilie nicht wirklich
seine torjägerqualitäten kam erst in
italien wieder zum tragen
nach seinem wechsel 2005 10 traf airline
für lazio 115 mal in der 163 spielen
hatten hervorragenden wolle ist sehr
zielstrebig und ich glaube das ist eben
relevant ist dass wir nicht allzu viele
chancen geben und ausgerechnet jetzt ist
dortmund defensive ausgedünnt mats
hummels bleibt als einziger
innenverteidiger der rest verletzt oder
gesperrt
in der dortmunder offensive jedoch alles
beim alten holland & co sind fit immer
ein tor mehr schießen als der gegner das
wird auch heute abend die devise sein
von videos könnten aus geheimen könnte
es noch gerne 2000 wir haben zum schluss
noch einen ganz dicken brocken meteorit
bello mit 4,5 milliarden jahren ist er
fast so alt wie unsere sonne war also
zeitzeuge als das sonnensystem entstand
deswegen ist die sonde osiris rex jetzt
mit einer art staubsauger zu ihm
unterwegs in wenigen stunden soll sie
aufsetzen mit gepresstem stickstoff sand
aufwirbeln den dann einfangen und zurück
zur erde bringen
mal sehen was wenn du uns zu sagen hat
das wetter bringt regen aber auch sonne
mehr dazu gleich von ostern terry
christian sievers freut sich auf sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal morgen
begrüßt sie an dieser stelle petra
gerster hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
dem zdf spezial und ich sagt tschüss
einen schönen ab wünschen
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein kleines sturmtief streift uns
morgen und bringt auf seiner vorderseite
warme luft aus dem südwesten zu uns ja
und dabei gibt es auch viel wind der
erreicht und seien am nachmittag und vor
allem nach nordwesten gibt es sturmböen
schauen wir in die nacht und da gibt es
in der nordhälfte viele wolken und es
regnet im süden ist es aufgelockert und
die temperaturen sinken dort auf drei
grad im bayerischen wald und 13 grad am
niederrhein
morgen vormittag vor allem im norden
noch weitgehend bewölkt mit regen
ansonsten nach süden aufgelockert mit
sonnigen abschnitten
an den alpen gibt es föhnsturm und zum
nachmittag da breitet sich der regen
weiter in den norden aus und es wird
allmählich trockener vor allem im süden
aber sonnige abschnitte nach nordwesten
hin sturmböen aus südwest und an den
alpen auch noch föhnsturm das bei
temperaturen bis 14 grad an der ostsee
und 23 grad im südwesten deutschlands
die nächsten tage gehen waren weiter
donnerstag bis 22 grad im süden sonniges
wetter nach norden viele wolken mit
regen und ab freitag nicht mehr ganz zu
warnen ein schöner abend